in the world of anime there's no
shortage of action filled anime with
spectacular fight scenes so we've done
our research and narrow down a list to
show the top 30 best fights of the
century starting off the list we have
Dalma versus Chang guran versus
double-headed snake visually stunning
freefor
all
this fight had one of the best sword
fights we've ever seen in some amazing
visuals the animation in Blade of the
Guardians truly stands out with how
gorgeous the entire battle looked and
how evenly matched it was dma's decision
to free the double-headed snake leads to
a free-for-all taking place with even
soldiers getting into the fight and
getting subsequently dispatched in the
coolest of ways the fight gains momentum
when Chang guran joins resulting in a
mesmerizing showdown between the three
Swordsmen the camera work showcasing
their skills with minimal Cuts adds to
the fight's Beauty ultimately darma
emerged as the Lone Survivor in a scene
that left a powerful impact but the
other opponents held nothing back either
this Chinese anime really had some great
scenes with this being one of the best
battles in
[Music]
it summertime render makes a list with
the fight versus the
Shadows
[Music]
if there's a show in recent memory that
so beautifully portrays determination
and resilience from a rag tag group of
people who put everything on the line
then it's summertime render I don't know
if a lot of you share my opinion but I
think this is one of the best shows to
utilize the time loop system and the way
it transitioned from some murder mystery
to Pure Thriller action is nothing short
of beautiful with this fight marking a
huge Turning Point an entire episode of
summertime render never felt as short as
this one with the human team combining
their skills to outplay shiday and H and
inching ever close to victory in
addition to the quota for Action being
filled is still filled with the various
mental gymnastics and strategy that I've
come to love the show for perhaps this
fight will encourage you to try the show
[Music]
out picture it edgy badass is ready to
throw down in a battle that's been a
long time coming like the Ultimate
Collision of an Unstoppable force and an
immovable object alukah doesn't waste a
second taking charge of the fight with a
flurry of familiars that leave Anderson
scratching his head but hold on
Anderson's got a surprise up his sleeve
enter Helena's nail his secret weapon
that transforms him into a monster
leveling the playing field against the
vampire just when things get wild SAS
swoops in for the save giving alukard
the Boost he needs the battle rages on
and our fanged hero manages to
outmaneuver and finally put the
transformed Anderson to rest in the end
alukard Stands Tall proving that when it
comes to vampire versus monster Paladin
he's the ultimate champ talk about a
battle for the
ages coming in all guns blazing we have
homura versus mommy from magical girl
Muka
magika if you saw a normal picture of
this anime and just read the name then
you'd probably assume that it's a cute
anime with magical girls it's absolutely
nothing of the sort and that's some
pretty insane fight scenes the best
amongst these were definitely the fight
between hom and Mommy since it involved
the flashiest scenes around their 1 V
one was filled with innumerable bullets
as the two shoot at each other to win
the fight had an absolute Banger
soundtrack and the environment was crazy
the bullet showers looked much like
fireworks and the pacing of the fight
was really fast so all these things
coupled with great animation made the
entire fight a sight for S eyes both the
girls were pretty badass in their own
way so seeing see them fight each other
just added to the coolness of it
[Music]
all next on the list we have Oya versus
the three masked Outcast from hior
noita this 1v3 battle is the type that
we've seen numerous times but just can't
get enough of it's a pretty short battle
overall but the choreography is just on
a whole other level you can see almost
every move the characters make and
they're all fluidly animated despite
having to fight three enemies all the
while being alone Oya stays calm and
composed he even deafly handles the
magic they throw at him also I never
thought someone handling a water bottle
would look so cool but Oya made me think
otherwise Oya had everything under
control for the entirety of the fight
and his finishing move look awesome
Chinese anime have really up the bar
with how amazing the fight scenes are
and this isn't even the last one of them
on the
list next up we have Trevor Belmont
versus death from
Castlevania Castlevania has some
spectacular fights but this battle
against death Takes the Cake and this
isn't some fake death it's quite
literally the Grim Reaper during the
initial part of the battle Trevor faces
off against the Grim Reaper but ends up
taking a harsh beating after this defeat
he rises again showing stronger
determination and proceeds to overpower
death turning the tables on the
situation in a glorious display of
fighting prowess the fight has some
stunning animation and a pretty sweet
soundtrack to back it up Trevor shows
off everything that makes him such a
cool character and the villain has Godly
levels of power considering the stakes
of the fight and everything else this
moment was definitely one of the top
fights of the
century
for the next entry we have Jin Mory
versus Han Davy from the god of high
school the best part about tournament
arcs is that sometimes you get to see
two Heroes fight against each other and
go all out because that's what you have
to do in tournaments this fight was one
such moment when two Heroes displayed
their powers and skills it was pure
Close Quarters combat with no magical
weapons involved and the choreography
huh it was stunning in every way
possible one of the coolest things about
the fight was that the camera showed the
scene from the character's point of view
as well and it looked
awesome F fights aside the next entry
will be going for a superhuman battle
between some of the strongest guys
around esano versus esosa from seven
deadly
sins
Oh
see now this fight had one of the
coolest openings before the fight even
began Ester Ro's commandment ensures
that anyone who displays hatred towards
him is rendered immobilized all of the
Holy Knights are affected by this except
escanor who says to eser Ro's face that
he feels no hatred towards those he
deems below himself this is the badass
start to escanor versus esosa and it
only gets better after that the way
escanor's Sun attacks are animated look
gorgeous and this was when escanor
wasn't even at full power the fight
showed escanor's pride in all its Glory
as he took down one of the strongest
Commandments the stakes were pretty high
as escanor's loss would have resulted in
numerous casualties even then it's hard
to worry when the hero is as strong as
the
sun next up we have Gava versus Anderson
from hajim no
[Applause]
[Music]
IO amongst close quarter combats this
fight is amongst the best Anderson is an
American worldclass Boxer while Gava is
a professional boxer on Japan's side
Anderson was a primary antagonist during
this Arc and Gava vowed revenge on him
after a few events that were less than
Pleasant that's what's fueled their
boxing match and led to one of the best
displays of boxing in anime the fight
between these behemoths kept fans on the
edge of their seats as each punch
counted the animation really holds up
even though it's almost a decade old and
each punch Throne feels so weighty and
satisfying watching gag got all out was
exhilarating especially because Anderson
was such a strong opponent this entire
fight is one that most fans of the
series remember fondly and that includes
us before we reveal the top 20 of this
list we have baky versus yujiro from
baky now quick recap by baky is out to
defeat his father the strongest fighter
in the world and for good reason since
yujiro is an absolutely ruthless Beast
nothing is off the table for this
villain and bky has been working hard to
defeat him now considering all of this
it isn't surprising that the fight
between the two would be highly
anticipated the fight itself is
incredibly satisfying with how long it
is and it's over-the-top animation the
two can't exactly be considered humans
either because of the Feats they
performed like jumping off a skyscraper
before the fight even properly began it
had some top 10 moves being dished out
from both ends and had some really fun
to watch choreography being such a long
awaited fight for fans of the series it
deserves a spot on this list
so coming in at number 20 is another
Chinese anime fog Hill of five
[Music]
elements this fight involves the two
brothers yishan and jingwan versus shanu
and the fight is just incredible the
anime itself has some gorgeous visuals
as every panel looks like something from
an art book the fight is fastpaced but
satisfyingly long the moves each
character pulls off are amazing to look
at and the fight choreography is just
top tier even the sounds are amazing the
fact that both brothers can go on out
against such an intimidating villain
really made the fight into something for
the history books the two have dealt
some major blows to shantu and one move
in particular that looked great was when
yishan punked jinwan to give him a
movement boost to attack shanu the best
part though is is when Yuan Powers up
into a Godly figure and just decimates
shanu up next we have another combo
fight with Asa and yuno going up against
licked after ASA and yuno defeated the
El's licked enters the picture as he's
reminded of the massacre of elves after
his wedding during the fight ASA gets
beaten so so badly that he loses his
black form and yo has to fight lied off
until ASA regains his form even with all
of that licked ends up beating the two
Heroes down this fight involves some
high-paced action and some pretty
awesome magic being thrown around back
and forth the parts where the anime
suddenly goes black and white also added
to the overall fight making it look like
something out of a manga panel by far
one of the best fights in Black
[Music]
Clover we aren't done with the duo
battel yet as next up we have midorya
and bakugo versus 9 from my hero
[Music]
Academia now this fight is one of the
flashiest we can see from my hero
Academia and the animators held nothing
back with it we get to see midoria Go
100% as well as bakugo and their attacks
look absolutely amazing nine himself is
an extremely overpowered villain as he
has nine different quirks due to the
power of all for one considering how
powerful he is it's no wonder that our
heroes had to go all out just to defeat
him the two Heroes even seemed to go
Super Saiyan at one point which was a
pretty cool moment the destruction of
their surroundings showed how intense
the battle was and every moment had fans
on the edge of their seats hard to think
the animators can Trump this fight
afterwards get
it
yes but before we continue I wanted to
let you know that your favorite anime
Community just got better I'm thrilled
to announce the grand opening of our
anime merch store we've got everything
anaku heart could desire epic t-shirts
hoodies posters and accessories every
item comes with an exclusive design that
you're not going to find anywhere else
these designs are like hidden jutsus
crafted by myself and our talented team
who understand the anime Spirit our
merchandise lineup will be refreshed
every season keeping your style game on
point so make sure to get it before it's
gone to celebrate we're offering an
exclusive discount for the first 100
customers use code early bird at
checkout for an extra 10% off your
entire order the Link's in the
description below join the anime fan
Revolution and let's rock these
exclusive designs together next on this
list we have one of the most hyped up
fights from JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
with jaro fought against
[Music]
Dio both these combatants have pretty
powerful stands but Dio's ability to
stop time is on a whole other level
besides this the fight was also the
final fight of the season and jaro
losing would have meant the end of the
joar bloodline JoJo's animation is
already awesome with how over the top it
is and the animators were keen on making
the final fight one to remember watching
both st's face off and Bash each other
senseless sounded amazing some people
may say it's a copout that starred
Platinum gain the power as do stand but
the show is meant to be bizarre so we'll
just take that in a stride besides who
didn't love watching Dio get pummeled
with a 100
[Music]
punches
coming in at number 16 we have kaneki
versus Jason from Tokyo G an
an now Jason is an S-Class goore while
gaki is the protagonist of the story
unfortunately for gaki though he ended
up captured and Jason put him through
mind-breaking levels of torture cutting
off his limbs repeatedly and making him
eat them to heal the entire situation
was exceptionally brutal and the torture
ended up breaking something inside gaki
resulting in a terrifying Beast so when
gaki was released we got to see him get
back on his torturer and things became
incredibly satisfying the entire fight
animation looks great and watching giki
exact his revenge was even better Jason
technically made giki into an
overpowered monster as he no longer
cared for his body and barely felt any
pain it was a fight that marked the
change in giki in a defining moment for
how you shouldn't push someone to the
brink of
insanity
up next we have mob versus mogami from
Mob psycho
100 now the animation for this series is
something that takes a bit of getting
used to to appreciate that doesn't mean
that the animation is something to scoff
at though and neither is mob's power our
friendly neighborhood esper had to face
an absolutely demonic evil spirit and
seeing its power you'd initially think
that there was no way mob could win this
one just kidding fans already know how
powerful mob is when he goes 100% And
this moment was one of the coolest mob's
Powers looked absolutely stunning during
the fight as the animators ensured that
this would be a fight to remember the
level of Destruction was of a
cataclysmic level and the two used the
entire city as a Battleground with both
characters decimating their surroundings
to top it all off the soundtrack was a
banger
sliding into the scene next up we have
gintoki versus dagas sui from
Gintama now Gintama is known for its
sweet comedy but the fight scenes in
this series are nothing to scoff at this
battle in particular between the two
Master swordsman was exceptionally
brutal and the choreography was stunning
the battle started off as a sword fight
but quickly developed into a brawl it
was pretty brutal as both characters
were left in PS of their own blood
during the battle the two were so evenly
matched that you couldn't expect who the
winner would be especially because
gintoki was already pretty exhausted the
Rivalry between the two has emotions
deeply embedded in their Roots so it
wasn't just a one-on-one battle but
rather a fight of ideals as well
everything in this fight was just
awesome so it's no wonder that it
deserved a spot on this
[Music]
list next up we have one of the best
fights from Demon Slayer when the gang
fought against DHI and guaro the upper
Moon
six we already know how big of a threat
the demons are as the demon Slayers have
to constantly put their lives on the
line to fight them the strongest amongst
the bunch is the upper moons and this
was the first time we got to see a fight
against them even with hashida tenen
uzui fighting with our protagonist this
was still a fight that was won by a very
small margin and did I mention how
amazing the animation was it was
extremely breathtaking The Clash was
just astounding and the moment when uzui
comes seemingly back from the dead to
protect Dano and fight off guyodo is one
of the most epic moments around the
colors the attacks The Sounds everything
is just topped here the animator sure
did give us a treat for the ages with
this fight and we can't wait to see what
more is in
[Music]
store near in the top 10 of this list we
have Spike versus is Vincent from Cowboy
bbop now this fight was amongst the best
close combat fight scenes we've ever
seen and for good reason but a bit of
background before that okay spike is a
bounty hunter while Vincent is a
terrorist they're both also exceptional
combatants and we get to see them in
action during this final fight the
choreography is superb and there's no
magic or any powers involved which
brings a rare realism to this anime
every strike feels authentic and the
characters paus catch their breath
showing they don't have infinite stamina
the martial arts depicted here feel
genuinely possible as something you
could see in the real world creating a
strong link between the audience and the
fight the visual effects have aged
exceptionally contributing to the
overall perfect atmosphere of the battle
did I mention how this was animated back
in 2001 definitely one of the oldest
fights on this
list moving away from the old but gold
type of fights you have a relatively
recent one when Levi fought against
Kenny and his Squad from Attack on
Titan now Levi's always been one of the
strongest characters in the entire
series and he's been a threat to the
Towering Titans so watching him get
cornered was something many fans
couldn't have imagined especially by a
human although it's worth noting that
Kenny akan is technically his mentor as
well besides the fact that he possesses
aim and blood all that aside this entire
fight scene was just incredible it was
so fastpac that you'd miss it if you
blinked and we had to see Levi meet
someone as close to his match as it
could get the animation was on a whole
another level and the camera angles
perfectly showcase the entire
fight but we aren't stopping here though
as we're finally entering the top 10 of
this list with sukuna versus mahaga from
jiujitsu
Kaizen this is one of the most recent
fights at the time of this video and one
of the best looking fights around sukuna
the king of curses against the to Shiki
gami from the 10 Shadows technique it's
worth noting that mahaga is a shikigami
that's never in its history been tamed
by any user of the 10 Shadows technique
because it has exceptional fighting
Power and the ability to adapt to any
and all attacks but sukuna is sukuna
he's called the king of curses for a
reason this fight was an iconic moment
that the series may not be able to top
anytime soon as it was just insane the
entirety of Shibuya was destroyed when
these two monsters fought it out and it
was accompanied by some of the best
animation recent
times all that aside we still have some
golden fights that are beloved by
numerous fans including Ichigo versus
olora from
[Music]
bleach we all knew that the big three of
shown and Anime were bound to appear in
such a list and the first fight from
those three is this one orora one of the
strongest espart amongst the Aon car
versus our hero was a fight to behold
orim was on the line during this fight
so the stakes were pretty high for
Ichigo the animation was pretty good
given when it was released and it still
holds up as we get to see these two
fight all out well technically UL Kora
didn't put in too much of an effort
before turning Ichigo into a donor
seeing Ichigo dead and then watching him
transform into a being on the level of a
vasto lord fans on a roller coaster of
emotions and led to one of the most
badass fights of the entire series you
definitely can't miss this
fight coming up next we have another
fight that hosts an absolutely iconic
moment when Goku fought against
[Music]
JM now Jen was an except exeptional
fighter who had amazing key control
great Ro strength speed and energy he
was so powerful that Goku could barely
keep up and was on the losing end for
the vast majority of the fight that is
until he finally unlocked the ultra
Instinct after the first time Goku went
Super Saiyan and this was arguably his
second most iconic power up of all time
I say arguably because he has a lot of
other Transformations but this was
exceptionally cool the fight was long
enough to satisfy any viewer and was
gorgeously animated everything from the
keyi blast to Planet busting raw
strength looked astounding coupling
everything from the iconic
transformation to the heated battle this
entry definitely deserves a spot on this
[Music]
[Applause]
list coming in at number seven we have
King Bradley versus Scar from Full Metal
[Music]
Alchemist G is a nameless serial killer
who's quite Adept to Alchemy weapons and
hand-to-hand combat on the other side we
have King Bradley the commander-in-chief
of the state military and an exceptional
swordsman their fight was extremely
brutal with both of them bloody and
wounded by the middle of it but the
Fight Continues with Bradley suddenly
turning the tables on Scar the end of
this fight resulted in Bradley losing
both his arms while at the same time
scar was pierced through the chest with
a broken blade he still won but threw a
little luck on his side as the light
momentarily blinded Bradley during the
fight we also got to witness a great
speech from Bradley as he tore through
most of Scar's attacks it was an amazing
fight overall and deserves all the love
it can
get next up is saitama versus boros from
one punch
man saitama's the strongest person
around capable of defeating anyone in a
single punch without even taking things
seriously everything about him is
overpowered and absolutely no one can
hold a candle to him but there was one
being that pushed him to the point of
throwing a serious punch and that being
was boros hey it's defeated itself to
get saitama to be even mildly serious in
a battle so it's a testament to boris's
strength anyway this entire fight was
just so good the animation was almost
perfect the battle was all over the
place but could still be followed it had
some pretty funny moments and yet at the
same time there was a certain sadness at
the end too the animation just took the
cake though and you could see the L
Studio bones had put into this fight a
long battle with perfect animation what
more could you
want nearing the top three entries of
this list we have Luol Lang versus
nanashi from sword of the
[Music]
stranger this was the final fight of the
anime and an emotional one to say the
least nanashi a master swordsman versus
Lu Lang his ability to ignore pain was
something that gave him a significant
Advantage during the fight but Nashi
persisted the battle took place in a
beautiful setting with equally brilliant
animation and choreography the two
characters used everything in their
Arsenal as well as the environment to
gain an advantage over the other and it
just seemed like there was no wasted
moments and everything was fluid to the
point of perfection there was nothing
flashy happening no gimmicks just two
amazing swordsman going all out we got
to see a beautiful fight and an ending
that tugged on our heartstrings truly
one of the best fights of the
[Music]
century before revealing the top three
of this list we have kiritsugu versus
kir from the Fate
series this climactic fight sets up the
stage for two characters who are
exceptionally strong and cunning to
finally find out who's better than the
other this fight was built up during the
entire series and it certainly deserves
the praise it gets beyond the well
established character motivations the
fight itself was amazing in regard to
choreography and animation the battle is
exceedingly brutal each Fighter's single
blow is so intense that it could
incapacitate most opponents gir
momentarily delivers a fatal strike to
girit zugu before Avalon intervenes to
heal him it was a short but sweet fight
and encompassed everything the fans
expected from these two
characters entering the top three of
this long list we have an absolute
iconic fight scene from Hunter Hunter
when Nero fought against
maruan now maruem was the newly born
King of the ants and right from his
birth he was shown to be a being on an
entirely different level compared to
everyone around him maruem was brutal
and ruthless and as such had to be faced
by one of the strongest hunters in the
series and this is where Neto came in in
his prime Neto was considered the most
powerful nen user in the world and he
retained his strength even in old age he
showcases his strength during the fight
with with meruem and boy is it a sight
to behold the way neto's praying is
animated and the badass moment he puts
on display during the fight even after
losing an arm and a leg lock him down as
one of the coolest and strongest old men
in anime in the end Nero had to
sacrifice everything just to beat the
overpowered maruem and still the fight
was one of the best of its
kind at number two we have another fight
that was highly awaited by fans of One
Piece which is the fight between Luffy
and
kaido now this fight has technically
been going on for quite a while but at
the moment what we're talking about
right now is when Luffy finally goes
gear five this moment was a game changer
and a major reveal of the entire series
fans suddenly got to know that Luffy
actually had the powers of a god named
NAA and then got to see all those powers
on display the fight was just Bonkers
and seemed like something out of a
Looney Tunes cartoon as Luffy man
handled the yonko and displayed some of
the most epic moves in the history of
the anime it just had so many amazing
stunts on top of the top tier animation
so it's definitely not a fight anyone
can
forget now
[Music]
me at the top of this list we have the
battle between Naruto and
Sasuke
the battle we've placed at the top is
the final battle between narut and
Sasuke which was a culmination of
numerous episodes that led to this point
fans of the series already know all
about the Rivalry between these two
characters and their interactions have
had pivotal consequences for the entire
Naruto universe so to tie up that
rivalry in a final battle meant that
this was bound to be one of the best
fights around the fight had perfect
choreography and amazing visuals and
both of these powerhouses used were just
stunning to behold the the battle
started with a good old fist fight
before more and more powerful Jutsu were
Incorporated until these two depleted
all of their chakra and then went back
to good oldfashioned brawling the battle
marked the end of a rivalry numerous
people around the world had been
following ever since narut came to
television screens and marked a
conclusive end with Naruto's worldwide
fans following this was a moment that
many people will hold in their hearts
forever and thus deserves the top spot
on our
list
and with that we'll be wrapping up this
list of the top 30 best fights of the
century with so many anime and so many
fights it's without a doubt that we must
have missed some of your favorites don't
keep us hanging though be sure to
comment down below the fights that you
consider the best of this Century if you
enjoyed this video give it a thumbs up
and subscribe so we can show you more of
this action-packed content see you next
time